okay bad baby bad baby Jeff woke up by
one weirdo an ex-con so I've never heard
of this game actually I have you know
people would saying it's a great game so
let's the [ __ ] play it I'm a [ __ ]
rookie
yeah there's a Vittorio okay here I go
Oh what is this
yeah she's hot line up at the site of
the great of course I'm gonna breeding
the formation she's hot Oh coalition
keeping with their promise to humanity
twelve new gene therapy clinics will be
opening in select cities that's the end
of the new year
despite the attempted attack by fringe
element operations at the new facility
in Paris thankfully remained unaffected
okay I love Jim darling but some repair
the eve of our most beloved celebration
the speaker which is after
a small number usually it looks like
could break the bond between humanity
and yeah as I say that eating forces
have already made several free Chateau
no collaboration advent I can assure all
citizens that today's celebration will
continue as planned
okay what'd I miss what'd I miss
I had to check make sure that was also
don't burn out a [ __ ] blissful
blowing yuzu how she done so sir Oh
scan is your 60 seconds can no one here
I'm [ __ ] talking yeah get a night
baby
oh [ __ ] better check his anus better
check his anus the [ __ ] is more Balaton
man it's like hello I don't speak
Spanish
okay louder clear that back okay your
turn
[Music]
yes salmon
let's take Lana no one knows what's
going on okay
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
one person a to person I am making think
of the book danke she's hot do that guy
okay we must move on his package
okay sorry a little bit tutorial you
need to get out of sight okay you got
that bad boy
okay so like that man whatever hmm got
in position but I'm exposed here it's
better than nothing but see if you can't
find a safer position further out yeah
[ __ ] looks like that's overrated full
copper bathing fall cover and shake
can't see that far
there we go get there glasha to stay
close keep pace with crasher one aah
crash our toes over here double time
no I can't to set of names it's not
gonna barely signify register [ __ ]
eyes you just gotta go in there okay
shadows until you're absolutely set
we'll only get one shot at this in the
shadows okay
okay perfect so how do you know that
still concealed though stay in low he's
[ __ ] or they don't see that you okay
thank you close you'll be spotted by
Sharon we'll lose our advantage
okay Jennifer over here
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh right there
can they not see me ironic okay we have
two numbers but we've got surprise on
our side hopefully that's not your bears
enough all right
oh no ex caliber this arrangers with the
[ __ ] going on we're not out of the
woods yet we need to take out those
remains you got it sister I got
permission to engage
granddaddy wink okay
press enter on an action button okay
okay okay okay okay what they want me to
do Johnny we're on an action button what
the [ __ ] the action button
oh there now yep
let's go Sam I'll a pad hey I just got
67 shot you just got right oh shut your
trap Jennifer they can see you now how
about you all shoot first and telomere
eight later no problem the [ __ ] I don't
want to learn initiate the bravery but
you're dangerously close right now
be careful you shut your [ __ ] mouth
pop good [ __ ] defeat what is that
weapon don't even school right now
exactly but okay that's right not going
out Betty oh [ __ ]
oh my god his [ __ ] no crashes too
much dog she's gone
damn it you can't pay attention watch
your flank
okay okay I was just
father tutorial but I feel blame me for
that death go ahead fire that's why fat
[ __ ] damn you like that [ __ ] now doc
doc [ __ ] doc oh say no more
I said Oh
the armor looks so bad
this bench crust shots a man or woman's
a man reporting it good thing central
sites that is disgusting no wonder we
killed us
Thanks they're us at least there used to
be human hybrid soldiers advents reward
for obedience and served by God my dad
wanted to but we find what we're looking
for today I promise you that's gonna
change
I'm good kid let's move imma say I'm not
surprised transmission went blue you
have an Advent transport closing on your
position
you heard her cover the left side what
is this
just gotta get the [ __ ] over there keep
your eyes peeled fire on anything that
moves and soldiers and over water shoot
the first enemy the prepare for it
reinforcements fire weapon and the main
entrance is clear we need to move on the
package
[ __ ] how far can I go okay wait hold on
a little confused Eric they said we need
okay sighs [ __ ] click on it [ __ ] Menace
3 you're up hold up you should check
that body for salvageable gear you need
anything we can get at this point better
move fast though I've heard rumors
Advent rigged their stuff to
self-destruct
let's go so okay let's get her out of
here over there [ __ ] get the [ __ ] over
there come on come on got okay good
oh [ __ ] Eric ambitious
looks like a [ __ ] turd
with lights on a canal Edie turn look at
these [ __ ] you think they're going
to get the dick sucked today but joke's
on that one has a cape holy [ __ ] they're
getting nervous now I know we're in the
right place
no it's okay
Kate man okay thank God fall back to our
position just go I'll try to stall them
here [ __ ] why don't you just [ __ ]
attack
why am I supposed to go somewhere and
exactly know where to go okay when the
[ __ ] is that blinking for what the [ __ ]
am I doing here
what the [ __ ] up
fire weapon why do I care - this guy
[Music]
yeah you know [ __ ] [ __ ] chance of
shooting I'm going for the door you
should be able to cut right through the
door security protocols they were never
expecting anyone to get this thank God
pack it pack it begin the hack begin it
we have to shut out that that was so
easy
okay let's say let's go let's go [ __ ]
in there turn the package she carry
packaged it now you're better let's go
baby
this is the place are you sure and as a
tube here so yes
what the [ __ ] is that it's the oh it's
Ultron yes
looks like there's an access panel
attached if you got me a better look I
might be next time
okay so slimy but man let's get out of
here okay
pingas has you carry great just without
firebrand is holding nearby for evac but
it's now or never central yeah I got a
sister
[Music]
chef she's got to get sick son yeah he
got a dicksuck no federal why sure what
is out you have to get out of there
well tell me what's a damn fetch we need
another exit
no I [ __ ] that okay come on Jan Kelly
fire in the hole pretty immersive
strategy I wish it alright ok got me
let's go bench what determines how far
they can go
I don't get almost there stay focused
great slow in like a [ __ ] oh great
she's gonna shoot that [ __ ] she is so
[ __ ] lucky way too close oh she's
done she's done fire breath this is
Gatecrasher we need an immediate evac oh
yeah my down here that's got a batch
keep moving you don't need to tell me
twice
all right Kelly we're coming home
you
a vac a vac all right leave one person
for the back good job good job
just look at that not sure you got a
nice ass though
[Applause]
there she's like how dare shag alright
first plus gut gut
yeah okay it's [ __ ] out Davis at
pinis me once shame on you
penis me twice shame on Shay careful I
betcha into the decade of atrophy to
contend with wish we had more time I
don't disagree
I never been now we risk losing the
patient if we don't begin to removal
procedure immediately what is it a jug
watch it be a [ __ ] Hedgehog with no
legs showing our face match a month in
the Hedgehog look 20 years ago
no idea what was coming
response from the cerebral cortex good
prepping for cranial intrusion that
rifle now yes
I've managed to identify the connection
preparing to make final incision these
readings are getting really erratic of
course they are these implants were
never designed to be removed we are
risking severe Plan B here people do it
oh you're getting a pregnant
[Music]
the [ __ ] tall
people are response normal vital
stabilizing the seizure complete okay
told them you will take more than that
to keep you down
welcome back commander I don't know if I
would just take orders from like a
[ __ ] capture recaptured Kostis well
glad to see you're finally coming out of
it don't envy the headache you must have
my penis hats are samurais I can't fault
doctor tuggin especially as no one's
even attempted something like this
before easy and I'm still not entirely
sure what they did to you that chip was
buried halfway into your skull at the
hotel keycard I left an iron soldiers
looking for you over the years almost
gave up hope you were still out there
acted on the Intel as soon as I got word
not sure what you remember this kind of
thing I really unlikeable guys changed
sir born did the best I could but the
last 20 years I've been tough without
you then you feel like catching up Shen
has the archive up and running on your
terminal
otherwise I'd go see dr. tagging when
you're ready there's some things you
should know you'll be better at
explaining them than me I need to know I
need to know it's damn good to have you
back commander okay ready
what okay racer shatters one thing I
need to know impressive isn't it capable
of generating immense power
you're completely harmless to human life
it's only the same could be said for the
rest of the alien technology commander
dr. Richard Tigers chief scientist at
the fire that bet I am responsible for
the entirety of our research here as
well as the procedures so we have second
deck to my life such as it is I'm not
sure what central may have told you but
we found something while removing you
from the alien stasis a device implanted
do so [ __ ] lock you're a speech app
that I access to the equipment available
to me during my tenure at add things I
would already know the precise nature of
its function
however given time and your approval of
course commander I assure you I will
find out which brings to light an
additional point what though aspects of
this facility are indeed impressive I am
but one man for you to direct additional
support personnel and resources to me I
could substantially improve the speed of
all farewell on your order commander I
will begin researching the advent chip
for possible insights as to its function
hey now I'll see that work begins
immediately commander I'll contact you
when I have a full report available
thank ya well that research will keep
Tigan busy for a while in the meantime
you might want to head down to the
armory
commander Jane Kelly was instrumental in
the OP to get you back
she earned enough experience for a
promotion we should say care of that now
she a transform serves as our primary
reconnaissance unit capable of moving
independently in concealment while
engaging enemies at close with all the
technology but her is [ __ ] Skype Pete
is like [ __ ] up okay Karen off to a
good start our troops will only get
stronger as they gain experience
commander to the bridge
I heard your shed when we get the thing
you'll be the first to know that cat
again holy [ __ ] my deck give me a second
execute a Shillong protocol ech alone Sh
I had wanted that to be a little more
ceremonious but we've got something what
a local resistance so just located this
hybrid magnetic power converter that
sheds been pushing us to find they
tracked the device to a nearby Advent
convoy and are attempting to take it
down if we can bring this converter back
in one piece we might actually get this
place up and running and give the aliens
a real war for a change huh
the squad is prepped and ready to launch
on your order commander just give the
word
let's go fetch
okay
operation headin Jess recover the Advent
compare work amazing okay Chuck shotgun
assault rifle shotgun
are you done he'd been Gary buy
something and excuse me
okay got and I get back down I thought
where I felt sorry for okay
she's the Ranger okay I can make a lot
more available
okay okay this bucket let's do this but
you ask if that guy max get on there
[Music]
okay maybe we have to actual plan out
resistance forces in the area have gone
dark
which can only mean one thing these
people sacrificed everything to give us
this shot we need to recover that
converter at all costs
traveling
and then you came off the drop okay
getting a fix on the device but it looks
like it may have been damaged during the
fight except energy readings are going
crazy I'm guessing we don't have much
time before it explodes okay Shen's
working on a way to stabilize that thing
provided we can get close enough to
access its core stay in the shadows
until we can get a better read on the
situation [ __ ] okay
to
double time double time batch double
time
yep come on
on it well she actually going up there
what the [ __ ] okay
fire where do I gotta go
no nose I guess that's fun hey where's
the [ __ ] alien technology that's over
there when I talk to my doing over here
solid copy
ready L am good T cool
I also have no idea where the aliens are
the Advent officers seem more capable
than the grunts we're not sure whether
it jug it up to training or stricter
mind control commander we have a chance
to do some serious damage here before
jumping into combat let's make sure we
make the most of our advantage let the
[ __ ] out I have to go play position
confirmed what the [ __ ] lads got my dick
sucked
already their objective position
confirmed okay you should be able to
hack into that thing safety protocols
and stabilize it Jen is uploading the
fix right now okay [ __ ]
because even target position now
okay [ __ ] this guy Dylan trying to get
his dick sucked in what Oh idea okay
that's good although they bear some
resemblance I can act towards first
encountered during the invasion their
genetic structure now includes human DNA
they are stronger than ever with an even
greater psionic potential sonic when
asked all right we're going to pop this
[ __ ]
what is that that's disgusting okay now
who's gonna Mateusz going to take the
first shot that's what I want to know
couch not again alright weapon yeah I
got a good shot to kill this [ __ ] kill
him
[ __ ] messed comater again these guys
make up the bulk of the Advent forces
we've dealt with they're disciplined and
well equipped but their obedience makes
them predictable okay he's right there
just [ __ ] calm
fire weapon now that's affirmative take
it now pop this [ __ ] there yay what the
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it
[Music]
adjusting sights Rangers are uniquely
equipped for close quarters combat in
the right situation it can prove highly
effective move it out okay kill this
[ __ ] what's up [ __ ] oh god that's
disgusting
I don't know what that was that's kind
of gross [ __ ]
the [ __ ] that mean he's walked right
oh great
yes suck my dick [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
here's what I'll do I'll just [ __ ]
move right there good copy
moving on top it and [ __ ] take on
this bench there like that they're
taking cattles do you like second on
penises okay
on it
let's do this okay sure that guy's going
to [ __ ] up right there [ __ ] what is
this [ __ ] doing it's okay I think I
[ __ ] in one second
no respite for the dead the aliens have
found a way to mind control them now not
great is he shooting after [ __ ] okay
that's this bench yeah okay here we go
commander we're running out of time here
if we don't stabilize the converter soon
I don't think anybody's going home today
okay okay
stabilize that how do the fraggin head
position confirmed
okay had a stabilized has a stabilized
and take you in the right spot okay I
can alien like right here
I'm on the move okay fry this [ __ ]
before you fries you target you tonight
fighting for my fast
great that's great
no I get him
why not now we didn't get him [ __ ] he's
angry
not even close [ __ ] headed there now
can I take this [ __ ] now right it's
[ __ ] face okay all right she gonna
shave this [ __ ] oh no oh she says okay
okay oh [ __ ] is a dude right there
[ __ ] a goodbye
okay [ __ ] at this batch that's sixty one
percent chance see when I say okay we
got hostile neutralized out of ammo here
yeah better do this let's see what we go
yeah uh he's fine I have a [ __ ] well
done chat returning to normal
well mostly normal firebrand is enroute
but I wouldn't take any chances
eliminate all remaining hostels in the
area before evac okay okay
42% chance
[ __ ] it come on Roli
it's pretty good okay see if I can shoot
this guy yeah we got him not like that
[ __ ] see going okay this batch is the
one that's going to terminate him now
this dispatch
[Music]
on the move okay you got to go for him
yeah 57% chance stupid [ __ ] enemy is
still gonna need to reload soon yes step
that batch I'm heading there now
okay on my way
all right fry that [ __ ] fryer can't see
[ __ ]
here's right there just get them there
we go doc
good job fine I tell status confirmed
mission accomplished
perfect thanks for watching babies thank
ya